so at this point you mentioned to me
right up the start if all I had was x to
the power of something I do know how to
integrate it add one divide add one
divide so let's just go through and do
it for this I am going to be checking
try and fit it on the bottom here okay
how about this one
what happens when we add one to that
index
x to the power 3 over 2. and then when
you divide by that right you've kind of
got a choice here depending on how
comfortable and fluent you feel with
this either and I often do this even
though I've been doing this for a
million years because I make so many
mistakes at this step I'd rather just do
an extra one I'm going to put that thing
all on the denominator is that okay why
do you think by the way I put these
brackets here on the denial area what do
you think is the point of that
like I couldn't I could have just
written it like this that's still
correct
yeah very good when I've got fractions
on fractions you're just asking to get
confused particularly when you've got so
many other things happening in your
brain so that's why why I do that
this one here
it's just a constant so what happens to
that when I integrate
yeah that's right
um I think that I I hear what you're
saying I would probably say I would
multiply by X because really I'm not
saying plus X I'm really saying times x
yeah but you knew what you meant uh last
one in here so I've got B squared
hanging out the front this bottle out of
the way what happens when we add one to
the index
there's the index right there
it'll be a half
and just like we did before I will
divide
by that
one term two term three terms am I done
with my integral
very good I need my constant integration
at this point the
that is done I just kind of need to tidy
it up a little bit right so for starters
fractions on fractions gross when you
divide by a fraction that's the same as
multiplying by the reciprocal so instead
of three over two on the denominator I'm
going to write two over three is that
okay
now
you probably could just leave that x to
the power of three on two
but I will tell you in a minute what you
would do if you well we can work through
what would you do if you didn't want to
that next term 2bx nothing to do there
can you help me out with this last one
what happens with that half down the
bottom
yeah very good 2B squared
and then that x to the half is still
there plus the constant you told me
about okay now I'm pretty content with
that that ought to get after all of that
I hope that gets relaxed um I will say
one minor thing um which is if you
wanted to be finicky about it um you see
how the question started there were no
uh negative indices or fractional
indices we introduced that what was the
reason again
it's easier for us to do this stuff in
indices right but often what we try and
do is provide back an answer in the form
it was given to us so just for the sake
of illustration if we wanted to
um what would this be without any
indices that you would write this as
extra three on two
have a think how would you write that
what's the simplest way you could write
it
yeah very good because really
this x to the power of three on two is
the same as x to the one and x to the
half can you see that's a three on two
right there so the thing you just told
me was X root x x there's root X Plus
2bx
plus you kind of just did this didn't
you that one's just going to be
square root of x
plus my constant but really you can see
by this point and just um if you were to
imagine if you were marking this if you
were the teacher and you got these
answers right and you were marking them
can you see the point of this question
is not really going can it's not me I'm
not trying to say can you go from this
line to this line I'm really trying to
see if you can do all this stuff so
that's why by this line I'm pretty happy
but I just thought I'd mention that
because a lot of people a lot of
students ask me like which one am I
supposed to do I'm like they're the same
it's not the main focus of the question
is that okay
so just before I send you off to go and
have another world at other questions
like that what was the thing that I did
that you didn't do can you tell me which
Step it was
I try to use what's in the formula sheet
I didn't understand how to do that so I
don't even it's like I was a non-starter
right the formula sheets supposed to
help you as a memory aid because there
are a bunch of questions that just fit
really easily you're like oh it's a
standard form it's what we call it and
you can just use the formula without
almost without even thinking right
um however there's only a small number
of questions that will be handed to you
in that really easy form
um usually you're going to have to do a
bit of work on it right
um just one last thing by the way
have a look at this question it's an
integration question but What proportion
of this question is actual integration
just just the very last bit right
um I would say like I don't know 10 of
the question is integration and the rest
of it is number one can you handle the
algebra and not fall into a ditch
because you just did some index indices
role something like that number two and
this is the harder part
you not only had to do the algebraic
manipulation successfully this part here
we really wrestled with right we had to
know how to choose what algebraic
manipulation to do in the first place
like this expanding thing
um I know to do it because I've done
tens of thousands of these questions but
you'll know to do it because as you saw
before you're like ah I'm stuck
it doesn't match any of the things that
I've seen before I've got to turn this
into something I know how to deal with
and by the time we get here
I turned this question which you didn't
know how to deal with into several
versions of this question that you did
know how to deal with does that make
sense
well you've still got me is there any
other questions that are traveling
question in general what would happen if
the pal was like a lot bigger than two
so are you saying if like
this power up here was like six or seven
or eight or something like that yeah
okay so
I will do better than um I'll do better
than saying like oh hypothetical let's
actually do one okay so if I gave you a
question like and you're gonna see in a
moment why I'm deliberately changing
this
um if I gave you a question like
integrate oh you guys gotta go do you
have to run to a bus or anything like
that
okay I um I have to go pick up my own
children so I won't make this super long
either but let me just give you a quick
example here uh let's suppose I did
hmm yeah I'm gonna do this
uh why not
here you go okay so your question was
what if that power up there was some
stupidly large power I'm like I can't
just expand right and in fact by the way
that's exactly what the question is
trying to tell you when you get some
number here that is impractically large
the question is trying to indicate to
you don't do it don't do it find some
other way okay now here's where and I'm
not going to tell you where on the
formula sheet it is but the formula
sheet can actually help you here right
this is a fairly simple function raised
to a power right so in other words it's
something like this some function
raised to a power okay now what I want
here is to if I if I were doing this
remember I drew the connection between
integration and differentiation
like 90 of the stuff we know how to do
with integration comes from what you
already know about differentiation but
just doing it in reverse okay so let's
just suppose we've got a question like
this you know the power is going to go
up when you integrate so I am just going
to guess the answer is going to be
something like
this right like the power went up okay
so I can test like I can say is this
still the right ballpark if I
differentiate this
right differentiate that
tell me what I get what happens
can we differentiate this do you
remember the chain rule what do I do
okay 11 comes out the front
yep so I'll write that there and then
come on lights you can do it okay
are you content with that
okay yeah sure I can just simplify
is this correct
you're like we did it
I think my students often end up with
massive trust issues after we went from
her it's fine it's perfect okay now this
is great it's very close to the thing
you want but it's off
it's off by a factor of what
33 right so all I need to do is if I'm
like oh if if this thing was say for
example 33 times bigger then I would
just reverse it I would say that's the
integral right now you can't just say
like I'm going to make a an easier
question because easy to interact with
right I have to make sure that this is
equivalent to the question I gave you so
if I'm multiplying by 33 here what can I
do to compensate for that to make it
balanced out what's yeah the opposite of
multiplication is just division right
do you agree that this question now is
exactly the same as the question you
started with is that okay so you're like
okay that one over 33 it just stays at
the front of the integral and then it's
just going to be this thing that you
mentioned 3x minus one to the power
level okay now the way that I would do
that like we kind of did that sort of
Step by Step by sort of reverse
engineering it right but the way I would
suggest you do that actually in the
question oh and by the way like before
constantive integration
is I would say what you did but not only
does this go up
and then you divide by that see how
there's 11 in here you also need to
divide by I divided by something else as
well what else did I divide by not just
11 there's a three where did the three
come from
it came from in here right because you
told me when I differentiated I had to
multiply by that so I'm just undoing
that okay so to answer your original
question if you get something like this
and you're like whoa it's a huge power
you are right in concluding they do not
want me to expand there's going to be
something else I can do here and this is
called the reverse chain rule by the way
if you want to go and look that up
however when it's a two
give it a go it's not that hard um you
know a lot about quadratics and even
though the the square roots make it look
a little gross you can see with some
patients we've got there